(upbeat music)
- Can I sit here?
- Yeah.
- Okay thanks.
- [Voiceover] Excuse me, sorry--
- Fucking people, come on
are you fucking kidding me?
- Hi.
- Aw, so dumb, so dumb, $50 worth!
- Seriously?
- Yeah, I'm allowed.
It's after rush hour.
Can you get my helmet?
- What?
- Move your feet over
that way, almost got it.
Yeah, uh, foot up a little more.
- Oh my god, this is the best night ever!
- We're gonna get so drunk!
- Oh my god!
- I'm already so drunk!
- Like, don't tell my mom
we're not gonna tell anybody.
(grunting)
- He's gonna go to hell!
Liquor is the devil's candy!
- Alright, everybody take a fucking seat.
Jesus Christ, can we go now?
(coughing)
Cool, yeah, no, let's just give
us all Ebola, great thanks.
- Last stop.
Last stop!
- Huh, we in Santa Monica?
- This is Silver Lake.
- Aw, man, not again.
(sniffing)
- Aw, man.
How are people pooping in
here without me knowing it?
I'm not cleaning that up.
(hip hop music)
- Sorry, I don't have any cash.
- I know you got dollars,
I know you got dollars.